oh oh my god
oh my is it worse than you remember it
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we welcome
him back to the hot seat it's t-pain
he's a bona fide hitmaker two-time
grammy award winner and has close to 50
billboard charting bops to his name
his latest single is get up and today
he's back for another go round with the
wings of death
t-pain welcome back to hot ones what's
happening brother how are you
i'm doing good if i recall correctly
last time around
you coated your stomach with milk to
help fight the spice
are you doing anything creative this
time around i am doing something
creative this time i have my milk on
deck but i
also have and and this is this
scientific fact right here
that is going to help i also have uh
slightly chilled tequila
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to pre-mess up my stomach
and then the wings should have zero
[Music]
effects
there we go all right let's do it oh the
classic
oh oh god
um
okay not bad
not bad so earlier this month you became
somewhat of an internet folk hero by
opening up your catalog of beats at
least the most recent ones
to streamers who want to use them for
free on twitch
as someone with a shrewd understanding
of both video game streaming and the
music industry
what do you make of this recent wave of
copyright takedowns that have swept
across platforms like youtube and twitch
i i don't know what the whole thing is
man i mean it's really free promotion
for all of us
you know artists and labels alike um
and the crazy thing is whenever labels
need promotion for their artists or
anything like that they always hit up
gamers
if you need the streamers don't disable
them i don't think it's fair what
they're doing but
luckily you have artists like myself and
a couple other dj's coming to the aid of
streamers and stuff like that so
you know it's uh it sucks but you know
we also got
some good people in this industry what
makes animal crossing
the ultimate toilet game
it's not a lot of stress you can do
things at your own pace you're actually
already living that life right now
what makes it the ultimate toilet game
right now is that it's a quarantine game
you're paying bills you're staying home
you making sure everybody else in your
neighborhood is good
and that's exactly what animal crossing
is and if we were in the hustle and
bustle
if i was on planes and stuff like that
then it wouldn't
be as fascinating to me but animal
crossing is just life simulator right
now
it's so green oh god
um oh that's good though
it's not bad so these versus battles on
instagram live have become a real staple
of quarantine and then your club banger
showdown that was two and a half hours
long with little john was definitely one
of the highlights
how do you go about putting together
your set list like you have to be
strategic on some level and think about
trap songs and how to set up the next
thing
yeah it was um it was actually a whole
process of you know thinking about what
john is going to play and
you know it's like it's like any other
competition man you gotta
kind of look at the highlights he's been
a dj for
god knows how long so i had a lot of
highlight reels that i could pull up
with little john to see what his
favorite songs are players and
me and my whole team kind of got
together and kind of put together like a
bracket list
of what we thought was coming next and
what we thought was going to be played
after what i played
but the whole thing really depended on
who was going first
because we didn't work that out
beforehand so i had to make sure that
john wasn't going to dust me
right at the beginning so i had the
bangers ready but i had another list
ready to go just in case
he wanted to go first if he would win
first i would have dusted it
there's this constant debate about
matchups that fans want to see
whether it's like nas versus jay-z or
diddy versus dr dre
what's an underrated match-up that no
one's talking about but should
i wouldn't say it wouldn't be fair but
it would be kind of weird i'd like to
see andre 3000 go against bitcoin
not only do they both have separate
careers but they also did that double cd
the speaker box in the love below i
would love to see those albums go head
to head
i think that's one that people aren't
thinking is a a good matchup but
i very much like to see both of them
together talking to each other again at
the very least
that's a weird thing oh it's hot dude
oh no don't you do it don't you say your
goddamn work
working at your pace working at your
pace my friend
[Music]
okay it's getting there it's getting
there
oh god i'm so glad y'all don't have to
see these whole wings
so anyone that's ever heard buy you a
drink knows that it's obviously
objectively a smacker but i'm curious
just from a musical perspective
are there details in that song that you
think propelled it to its level of
popularity
when i made the beat i didn't think it
was going to be like a giant song but
when i started writing the lyrics
and started putting in lyrics from other
people's songs i think that
really propelled it to be like oh my god
this has
all my favorite songs in one dope song
so once i made it i was so proud of it
i walked into chris brown studio and
showed it to chris brown
and he tried to take it from me
he was like oh my god he looked at his
manager like we got to get ready we got
to get this on my album
and i was like yeah man for sure not
whatever you want and i was just
i was just defeated at the time and then
as soon as he as soon as i left out that
room man i was like he's not
ever hearing that song again until it
come out i'm never
that sorry it was my father being too
excited
i know chris wanted that song i'm sorry
chris i love you man but
i needed that one brother
[Music]
oh boy
i can't really taste that the other guy
oh yeah
oh you see musicians flex phantoms all
the time but i've never seen anyone
ride as hard for budget compacts the way
that you do
why are scion xb's and mini coopers why
are they so special to you
it's just too much sometimes it's too
much i can floor
my mini cooper for 20 minutes on the
highway just pedal to the middle
going super fast over 100 miles an hour
totally fine let you floor a bugatti for
30 seconds
now you got to replace radiators each
radiator is 25 grand
and there's four of them in the car but
if you break one
you got to replace all of them what is
that what
german what come on what is that
owning expensive cars it's the worst i
hate it and i don't know why we
moved into that and i don't know why
rappers before me made me think it was
going to be easy-peasy
especially if you got 19 of them that
was not fun
i had a bitly gt i had it for one
day i parked it at the studio so i can
go out of town and come back the next
day
came back the next day whole studio
flooded out
whole thing my car was underwater
and let me tell you if that would have
happened in a mini cooper i would have
had another mini cooper the next day
but being that it was eventually gtc
there was no fixing couldn't get it
fixed had to let it go i bought a
bentley couldn't get any money back
flooded out nobody wanted to fix it it
was two water damage
bentley out the door just stupid
[Music]
we may have sauced these too much
you gotta roll that r man you gotta
figure that out
that's really good so you've long been
one of the culinary world's most
underrated thinkers and last time around
we explored some of your amazing food
takes that you delivered to the internet
this first one really hit home for me
because there was a time where one time
i ate a taco from the top
and the internet roasted me for
literally months on end and recently
you tweeted [ __ ] trying to tell
me i'm the wrong one because i eat
burritos sideways
i'm not gonna be a part of your liberal
society cuz
people care way too much about how you
eat something you know yeah it's really
crazy man i don't see
how it's gonna affect anybody else's
life but the good thing is
that that you know i try to tell people
of why i do that because when you eat
a burrito sideways it turns into a taco
eventually
so you can't devalue my my thoughts
because
you've been taught to eat your things a
certain way i'm sure
there are people out there that eat
burritos regularly in front of people
then they go and try my method and like
oh my god this is much better but i can
never show anyone
and that's just not cool man be proud of
how you eat burritos
ever notice how long it takes to leave a
restaurant like from the second you're
ready to leave
time it next time see how long it takes
okay while you're eating
waitress or waiter is there non-stop
they won't let you eat they keep talking
to you while you're trying you've got a
mouthful of food
but how's everything tasting i'm eating
it i haven't spit it out yet this should
be an indication
from across the room that i'm fine but
then
when you're done all the plates are
empty everybody's down they're just
chilling nobody has their hands on the
table anymore
the restaurant just shuts down nobody's
there anymore
nobody's coming to see how was it here's
your check
do you guys want anything else do you
want to order the souffle that's going
to take 45 minutes but it's okay if you
wait
nobody wants to come at that point and
then it just takes it takes like
double the time it took for you to eat
for you to leave
and i it's just the weirdest thing in
the world all right
one more for you t-pain bro i just ate a
chicken nugget
that was an experience that was an
experience i was uh
at a company called just what they were
doing
were making vegan food products like
eggs chicken nuggets
and things out of sales of living
animals and that process is so
extensive and and so elaborate that each
chicken nugget at that moment
was 200 bucks and they make eggs from
the same process
nothing's different about it it's just
you don't have to
murder an animal every time you want to
eat it so
it was actually pretty cool it was
actually really good
[Music]
seafire gourmet reaper
that don't make any sense
how do you know what's the process of
picking hot dogs
so i'm happy you asked that we uh
[Music]
we have a hot sauce plug noah from
heatness he helps us figure this out
every year
noah we ain't friends bro
wait oh my god
so when you won the masked singer as the
one-eyed monster
you described it as an f you everybody
moment
oh son ah
[Music]
when i went to bad singer to the people
that didn't know
what i was capable of and you know i've
had over the years
you can imagine oh my god my spit is
spicy what is going on
um over the years you can imagine how
many people have been calling me the
auto-tune guy
you know all i know how to do is do
auto-tune i don't have any talent
they don't know that i've been producing
all my albums and producing and writing
for other people so
when i took that mask off it was like oh
my god
it was just a great moment like that's
right [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is how this works huh
i should have cheated why did i do this
correctly i should've
you know we could not we could not
police it you know
why the [ __ ] that we really are on the
honor system
oh my god what are you gonna come check
oh my god
[Music]
okay okay we try to keep the integrity
of the show
that's why because we love you man i
know you can't respond your eyes careful
around your eyes yeah i just wipe my
mouth with that same thing this is not
going to be good in about 20 seconds go
ahead though keep going
all right let's move on we'll keep it
moving this is thor's hammer
thor's hammer in the seventh spot it's
very hot
[Music]
oh my god
so this year marks the 10-year
anniversary of freaknik the musical
an animated special about the infamous
atlanta street festival that you produce
and starred in for adult swim
as someone who loves cartoons more than
anyone i've ever met in my life
where does that particular project stack
up against some of your other major
[Music]
accomplishments
grammys okay that's other people judging
what you do and other people
coming together and saying who's better
at what but
having something in your mind and having
something come out the way that you
imagined it and it'd be so successful
that we had
two million more viewers than than
than a particular award show that was
happening at the same time
i think i think that was uh i think that
was one of my that was one of my
crowning achievements man it was pretty
good
that was good
do you have a mount rushmore of cartoons
a top four of all time
ooh chowder
my hero academia squid billy
rick and morty's in there for sure no
question i am running out of napkins
this is
ah
[Music]
well i don't know if you recall this one
uh this is the bomb beyond insanity at
the eight spot
my tears burn i don't know why that's
happening
my tears are burning my skin
ah oh it tastes like gas
[Music]
ah
oh
ah [ __ ] you noah
so i've heard that when you go to a
strip club you'll have the manager turn
all of the tvs in your section onto
cartoon network
what are some other moves that separate
a veteran in the strip club from a noob
um spending money when you don't have to
there's no reason to spend as much money
especially if you know
you're going to do something later
this is so much worse than last time
[Music]
are you in atlanta right now yeah we
shot hot ones the game show in atlanta
what can you tell people about the
claremont lounge
it's the best chip club ever known to
man
there's a 80 year old stripper in there
and she [ __ ] works it boy
i'll see where she wouldn't tidy why
does it know let's go
oh god i'm gonna throw up this might be
the hardest question that we asked this
entire interview but to put you on the
spot
what do you think is the single greatest
all-time t-pain strip club anthem
long left dance song for sure it's the
longest one
and it'll get you the most it gets your
most out of your dance
okay
[Music]
oh i don't think
hope they just get worse
so you've been through all the highs and
lows that you would expect from somebody
who spent
15 years in the music industry but the
thing that i admire about you most
is that somehow someway you're able to
grow through these moments and come out
with a fresh and new perspective
how do you view the role of a record
label in 2020
there seems to be so much tension
between artist and label but
nothing really changes the model stays
the same
i think the world of the world of
information has grown so much oh my god
the world of information has grown so
much that artists can now see
what the labels have been doing and how
they've been making money it was a
secret for a long time
but now i think that artists know
what the labels are doing and how
they're making money that the labels
have become
unnecessary in success the artists have
realized that what labels do
isn't some superhuman power that is just
unavailable to everybody else and i
think that
that is where artists are at this point
this sucks
okay you ready i'm ready
hear that cheers
ah
[Music]
okay okay all right t-pain here we are
on the last stop in the show and i know
that you've been pushed to the brink
today but one thing
that i love about you is that you are
the fun guy
you're always so much fun and i remember
the first time that you came into the
studio
you were like hey sean what's up you'd
already seen all the episodes you knew
exactly where you were in the line and
i'll never forget that about you i'll
never forget that about you
so now coming back here and doing it a
second time
dying stomach twisting sweating from the
face
yep as someone who's able to find the
fun and everything
what do you find fun about this
the interview part man just you sean and
you you as a person man
you know it's not if it's usually
on stuff like this the host wouldn't do
it at all the fact that you do it with
people and the fact that you are
our actual friends and you you actually
look after us and stuff like that man i
think it's you that makes this show
so damn great man it's you know we go we
do
we do interview on top of interview on
top of the interview every day
and it it's great that i can agree to do
an interview with you because you
actually
go deeper into things you actually do
the challenge with us
you actually uh give a [ __ ] if we are
throwing up or not
uh it's just it's it's a it's a level of
respect between
interviewer interviewees so it's youth
that does his whole thing man
judah makes this fun and you're just
such a cool [ __ ] guy
and i think we all just love you more so
than doing this dumb [ __ ]
you know i wasn't expecting that but i'm
really touched by that and thank you so
much you've always got a friend in me
absolutely now it is my honor t-pain
to roll out the red carpet for you this
camera or possibly a camera b
if you've set one up let the people know
what you have going on in your life
you know right now pain and torment
um the new single get up
um all proceeds oh my god
i think it's worse all proceeds go to
crime survivors for safety and justice
uh it's an organization that i've been
dealing with for a while and make sure
you go to pizzlepack.com if you want
that dmca free
music for your streaming purposes for
twitch
mixer facebook gaming uh
youtube whatever you want uh
oh my god
ah i hope you guys are safe corona free
and if if not then i i hope you guys get
better
i love you all love you sean oh
jesus [ __ ] [ __ ] you noah
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in
with one camera guy how you doing steven
you good good steven's good there's no
one else in this building except for the
two of us
it is locked down over here but you know
what the pepperdome is open for all new
episodes of hot ones the game show
tuesdays on truetv the pepperdome
see you there if you dare